in this segment and the next two we will
introduce a few useful random variables
that show up in many applications
discrete uniform random variables
binomial random variables and geometric
random variables let us start with a
discrete uniform a discrete uniform
random variable is one that has a PMF of
this form it takes values in a certain
range and each one of the values in that
range has the same probability to be
more precise the discrete uniform is
completely determined by two parameters
that are two integers a and B which are
the beginning at the end of the range of
that random variable we're thinking of
an experiment where we're going to pick
an integer at random
among the values that are between a and
B with the endpoints a and B including
and all of these values are equally
likely to be more formal our sample
space is the set of integers from a
until B and the number of points that we
have in our sample space is B minus a
plus 1 possible values what is the
random variable that we're talking about
if this is our sample space the outcome
of the experiment is already a number
and the numerical value of the random
variable is just the number that we
happen to pick in that range so in this
context there isn't really a distinction
between the outcome of the experiment
and the numerical value of the random
variable they are one and the same now
since each one of the values is equally
likely and since we have so many
possible values this means that the
probability of any particular value is
going to be one over B minus a plus 1
this is the choice for the probability
that would make all the probabilities in
the PMF sum to one
what does this value what does this
random variable model in the real world
it models the case where we have a range
of possible values and we have complete
ignorance no reason to believe that one
value is more likely than the other as
an example suppose that you look at your
digital clock and you look at the time
and the time that it tells you is 1152
and 26 seconds and suppose that you just
look at the seconds the seconds reading
is something that takes values in the
set from 0 to 59 so there are 60
possible values and if you just choose
to look at your clock at a completely
random time there's no reason to expect
that one reading will be more likely
than the other all readings should be
equally likely and each one of them
should have a probability of 1 over 60
one final comment let us look at a
special case where the beginning and the
end point of the range of possible
values is the same which means that our
random variable can only take one value
namely that particular number a in that
case the random variable that we're
dealing with is really a constant it
doesn't have any randomness it is a
deterministic random variable that takes
the particular value of a with
probability equal to one it is not
random in the common sense of the world
but mathematically we can still consider
it a random variable that just happens
to be the same no matter what the
outcome of the experiment is